search is still on for the driver who
killed a 15-year-old boy last month the
hit-and-run happened in the southwest
valley on durango near warm springs
that's where we find madison kimbrough
with the latest details
people across the valley this is the
time to be extra vigilant out on the
roadways as detectives are looking for
this a red dodge charger with driver
side mirror and windshield damage
specifically a missing driver side
mirror the year of the vehicle could
range from 2015 to 2017. this all
happened on september 10th around 7 45
in the evening keith young jr and his
younger brother were crossing durango
against a traffic signal when young
junior was struck by the red charger
traveling northbound on durango
according to a witness the driver then
took off young junior was taken to the
hospital where he later died currently
there have been over a hundred traffic
related fatalities in metro's
jurisdiction already surpassing last
year and as you can see there is a
memorial set up with candles and flowers
at the crosswalk where this incident
happened if you know anything you were
urged to contact metro immediately you
can also call crime stoppers to remain
anonymous reporting from robindale and
durango madison kimbrough live local now